c'est la fin idéale
j'ai 30 ans au journal vous lirez
nouvelle j'espère qu'elles seront chauds
société brian grant thorton cna est
bannie bave sur qu'outil des petits
comera le grand et le petit écho de la
forêt c'est la trêve re s'est déroulé il
y à toutes les informations à chaque
nouvelle édition on n'a jamais de
déception ça vous le découvrirez dans
l'homme tu t'es cours de l'offre
[Musique]
[Rires]
voyons voyons voyons que dit notre
journal il ne dit pas grand chose mais
si mais si
oh écoutez chers téléphone il faut de
tout pour faire un monde et c'est bien
vrai il faut des téléphones des hiboux
et bien d'autres choses encore mais oui
mais oui il m'a répondu je ne sais pas
il n'a répondu celle faut me sens si je
n'ai rien contre les renards mais c'est
quand même une drôle d'aura c'est vrai
en plus ils sont révoltés matin
cependant de son côté louis le retard il
devine ce qu'elle m'a répondu rêver
c'est pas ça leurs deux noms si à
l'écrit rien voir les fruits mais c'est
quand même une drôle de razz c'est vrai
elles sont bavardes avare médisantes
égoïste de son côté tosca la tortue
avait couru mais oui couru et
mademoiselle de la cigogne
si maintenant les radars se permettent
d'insulter les fournier
remarquez ce n'est rien contre les
renards mais c'est quand même une drôle
de maintenance et de la cigogne était
allé informer les deux frères castro de
ce qui était arrivé à renard n'a pas le
droit de répondre ainsi aux animaux au
lait mais louis est aussi un animal en
est ça reste à prouver au pourquoi parce
qu'il est un renard et alors alors c'est
tout et c'est assez très inquiet de la
tournure des événements les deux frères
k stores allait revoir louis le renard
même un bon lot et m'écoutent arrête de
pleurer comme ça et va mouiller tout tu
es fou rue
je suis
et alors ils aiment les deux frères
décidèrent de réagir très vite ils se
rendirent toutes affaires cessantes
c'est mademoiselle de la cigogne
pourquoi me regarde et vous ainsi jeunes
gens parce que vous avez des plumes
blanches et alors ces avis sont minces
masse trouve ça un peu bizarre
pertinents on n'a pas droit parlait
ainsi aux animaux honnête quand on a des
plaies ou large croyable
nous n'avons rien contre les singles
mais c'est une drôle de race scandalisé
de ce que la vie autour du mademoiselle
de la cigogne se précipite dans le
potager de tosca way tous cas ils ont
dit que les cigognes était une drôle de
race
je ne suis pas raciste mais les cigognes
sont une droite
je vous en prie vous n'êtes qu'une
tortue après tout et les tortues sont
une de retard
je sais c'est tant pis pour vous et
quand on n'est qu'une tortue
on a la pudeur de se taire tosca
complètement démoralisé 1 à se faire
consoler par boris le loup mais
moi pas du tout raciste la plèvre aimait
beaucoup le loup
pourtant mon petit colis ou sans gros
fans ont une bonne chance et de la race
dit long on se casse une immense
tristesse s'était abattue sur notre
forêt que les autres d'être une cigogne
famille et moi un renard et guintoli
oualalou et nous dit que la sto cessé de
pleurer mais habite arras importe peu
l'important c'est ce que nous sommes au
fond de nous mêmes regardez moi je suis
encore bout est-ce que j'en fais une
maladie croyez moi il faut de tout pour
faire un vent de ce cher boxe a bien
raison de sport ch téléphone il faut de
tout pour faire un bond